revenons au match lui-même qui a vu la
victoire du PSG 3 à 1 devant Bastia les
Corses se sont bien batttu face à un
champion en forme cert mais bien content
d'en finir quand même le résumé du match
et les commentaires de Denis Ferd voilà
c'est fait 50 ans après un club Parisien
le PSG est champion de France Jacques
ouvrait le score de la tête face à
Bastia pour le parisgermain l'attaquant
parisien allit récidiver sur un centre
de SIC d'une superbe tête plongeante
les nouveaux champions de France vont
toutefois s'incliner devant des Corses
très combatifs cetti débord et testa
marque bat cette fois ne pouvant
rien finalement c'est le capitaine du
PSG qui va clore le score sur penalty
Fernandez signant ainsi son dernier but
sous le maillot du
parissgermain victoire représenta pour
moi le titre de champion de France avec
mes partenaires et tout ce que l'on a
réalisé cette saison je crois que on a
quand même été premier dès la deuxième
journée jusqu'à l' dernière et je crois
que cela c'est un exploit et pour une
fois qu'une équipe pour la deuxième fois
qu'une équipe parisienne est championne
de France je crois que on peut tirer un
grand coup de chapeau et mes partenaires
comme mon entraîneur et comme les
dirigeants je crois qu'il méritaent cela
après 8 années que je suis à ce club que
que l'on réalise enfin ce grand
événement d'être champion de France les
supporters ont été vraiment formidables
au cours du match et et au cours de
l'aprèsmatch ils nous ont vraiment
montré leur leur sympathie pour nous
leur leur our qu'il nous porte et je
crois qu'on leur a bien rendu en leur
donnant ce titre de champion de France
c'est une saison qui a été tout à fait
fabuleuse pour pour tout le club parce
que vous parlez de semi-échec en Coupe
de France vous savez quand on a tout
entrepris pour pour ne pas perdre et ça
a été notre cas au cours des deux matchs
il n'y a pas à rougir de notre
élimination contre Bordeaux et puis ceci
dit réaliser 26 matchs sans défaite
terminer champion de France qui pour à
mes yeux représente la plus belle
consécration sur une saison
je pense qu'on peut dire un grand bravo
et un grand merci à tout le monde ce que
je ressens c'est c'est une joie intense
intérieurement que j'apprécierai
peut-être encore plus en famille ou avec
mes amis ou avec mes tout proches et que
je n'ai pas encore totalement le temps
de réaliser tellement le rythme était
fou ces derniers temps parce que je
pense que depuis un mois et demi ou de
mois nous jouons tous les 3 jours pour
l'instant j'ai prouve une grande fatigue
mais je sais que je vais bientôt
apprécier